uh so help me out here you got Lord
tattooed on your throat and then you
have the upside down cross
how we feeling about Jesus destroy
lonely are we [ __ ] with Jesus or not
angry which yeah give me your religious
because you know a lot of people think
[ __ ] Cardi's a [ __ ] Satanist I'm
atheist I don't give a [ __ ] about none
of this [ __ ] for the record bro this is
so good but you have a pretty you have a
pretty cool like Dynamic of like Lord
upside down cross like I don't know what
to think
what's your religious stance buddy I'm a
spiritual person yeah in the civiliz
terms I believe that it's something
that's helping all of us and that's
about it I don't know who it is but [ __ ]
I just believe in that Lord no that's me
I'm the Lord of this [ __ ] I ruin this
[ __ ] world I always tell people like
I believe in you do you feel me more
than I believe in like
whatever the [ __ ] they tell us to
believe it in these books that are man
written and I personally I'm gonna lie
see I ain't you gonna make me start
talking but I feel I mean this is an
interview so please please please talk I
got my own philosophy to how this [ __ ]
works so like I said I'm like Lord this
is for me it's for whatever the [ __ ]
else too but like I got my own
I know how this [ __ ] play out for me so
I feel like um all right come on man
this is the [ __ ] Insight man I don't
know like very it's just like you in
control of your own life like you know
what I'm saying yeah there's something
that helps you entity whatever because
it's right [ __ ] that happens that you
can't never explain I don't give [ __ ]
what nobody said but it's like
[ __ ] Works a certain way there's no way
for me to explain it honestly for it to
make sense but [ __ ] Works a certain way
and if you could tap into how that [ __ ]
work and you go with the flow of that in
the sense of your life then everything
will work out for you later so you gotta
tap in by eating mushrooms I guess or
it's just doing whatever the [ __ ] you
want a lot of people let other people
tell you to like do [ __ ] when you can
like
you know what I respect I respect
scientologists on a whole nother level
because it is so batshit crazy and the
fact that they [ __ ] represent that
[ __ ] I see that commercial for that [ __ ]
though you're like if you didn't hear it
from us you haven't heard anything
there's a whole TV channel it's called
the Scientology of course that's it it's
crazy it's a wild thing so the guy who
created Scientology uh L Ron Hubbard
he's the most highly published author of
all time so he's written like a bunch of
non-fiction books from like the 50s 60s
and 70s but then he just decided to
create a religion and now he's got tax
exemption but that's what I'm saying
because I genuinely feel like like
that's what I mean with the philosophy
[ __ ] like music quote fan bases whatever
anything can be religion if you believe
in it so it's like
what the [ __ ] you just said this [ __ ]
just created his own religion and
there's people that follow that [ __ ]
[ __ ] make their own songs Tom Cruise
follows it Tom Cruise is as big as one
of the biggest actors in the world
people make their own type of music now
everybody make that type of music like
anything could be a religion anything
could be would you ever start your own
just for tax purposes got my religion
it's called destroy lonely you should
try to apply for the uh the tax benefits
of that hell yeah because if you have a
religion I gotta get a church I need a
church you need a church yeah say this
say this You're Gonna Save a lot of
money trust me bro you're gonna run it
up for sure